there I am only navy grandchild developed
android team routine
I'm here today to talk a little
about a new android 4.4 feature that
are the new good sms apis in a 24.4
kitkat has a new concept in relation to
the use of the default sms application or
now from version 1.4 only
to this pattern you can send write
directly in the sms content provider
of the android system any other
time you try to do this will fail to
silent form or the user does not
will be limited warned but it is not
it will be able to send the sms it's good
other areas can continue reading the
semesters normally
okay since of course they are using the
right permissions on the good system
because it has a standard ep which is the
advantage because it had this change in the
good paradigm
first because the standard ep is going to have
guarantee to receive all messages
that arrive at the device is another
that can not interfere with or abort this
process then increases the reliability
good cms delivery
another thing is that no other ep can
delete or change messages behind the
ep and then decrease the complexity
because we will have the behavior
centralized in an application and clear
allows third-party cement apps
or yours is for example supported from
way to appear and main system
is to ask for first category let's go
call it is not because the user has
direct interaction with her is very
cool to know that your ep can be
main engineering sms good and for
implementing this is good because an epe
to be eligible is because it can be a
The standard sms team is obviously got
that having some prerequisite has to
have some specific skills
good
the first thing is of course have a blog that
is accessible to handle messages
received tatá and on the screen are there
So are you doing the kessy blog?
performances and also a great
complaint if you deploy the mms received
well you gotta have it so to say
declared in your manifest and make the
Also good implementation also
Of course I had was that the user
can send new ms ms is after all how
What if you want, sir?
be active default has to give to the
user a way to send this
message is good there is also a
quartermaster filter and how do you
I would configure the one I had in order to
send good message and beyond
also has a service that delivers
the phone's message of quick way
response is also has the service with the
intendant son that you can use
and so remembering what I said now
are these requirements are basic
your ep may be the system default
because only then will the system
continue to ensure that the user has
all the available SMS
Your phone is good and there.
in case he will get a warning like this
where will you ask to reach a standard
is and if you want to use this as
a standard the user will respond that
yes or no of course you do not have
to interfere with the user's choice is
then the user will have this option
choose and choose from the
be the wonder pattern ball forward
will seize this opportunity there
Good thing we do to receive the
sms messages
good has new action specific kitkat
to receive is the delivery of messages in the
case is the live action sms and oak bush
live action
and the actions of the messages received are not
that he when he receives the message is
when you have a sms received action and oak
push and civil action
then you have to map these
according to your ability to receive
and also to treat when the
receiving the message is good good
some best practice in terms of
have a personal sms application to
they do not look for standard cieps then
I did an ep that at the time was to send
sms template something you
but it does not have goals and it is
continue using the
rehipment actions reef
it does not change anything you've been doing
but if you already have a time
That way, do not worry, without it.
worry if you want to be an epe
pattern
good if you want to be one is tactical standard
to pec - already 1.7 component and neither will
settings because you can not
disabling components with receivables
from merced even messi received or is
prevent anyone from attempting to intercept
message because it's you who will receive
all messages and also one thing
very important use resources in
files from 6 boolean years to
enable or disable automatically
receivables
according to the version of the platform that
I see quickly how you are going to use it.
that you can have the compatible type
both with kitkat and with versions
earlier is good
this for example is how you create a
I'm afraid, so here's a reservation.
the variable name né and the value can be
trump faustão in case leaving as
default that has false and false khat
pre kitkat tron ​​and already provel luiz dash
see 19 or the platform in the version of the
pm it takes 19 I'm talking about having kit
kat tron ​​is that the qat building is fake
It's so showing there in that way.
search in iff in code 11 reservations and
which according to the version is configured
indicating good trio or fauci values ​​and
There in my manifesto when I go
declare the reef is good staff
so in the case of the kat kit receipt I
I'll put boolean recipe
indicating that it has a kit and in the case of
building that's aunt I'm going to use then the other
variable by black cats is there
address with qr code you can
give a read and take any further questions
here it has been good and for
verify that the application is the default
perhaps offer an ease of making
the standard apps first thing by
example there is a method where the examination was
sms is where I'm checking if it can
be the sign the default is not verified
first is in the kitkat version for
to be able to know if I can you ask
by a system and if it is then I do the
that I give a return nec is a Goian
comparing I get with 3.7 pec-g name
which is the name of your current context and
compare with the phone tips ms.gov.br
phone sms today and the context
so if the goal is standard
return a snag will get false and then
in an abstract about captive for example you
Can you turn it on or off, right?
an option on wai offering to make your
standard sms application or not
not only goals you application it is not the
you can display an icon there
that he can click and make the
application and how you apply
that the same client user there you have
What do you do that is terminating?
default was the code is also very simple
just create an understanding with
correct settings and there will appear
there is the request for the eyes are
watching on the screen
if he wants to make that application
standard for sms or not good
some notes we finish this
notice there message we go
continue to ship with any
team using send sms permission
using sms - go to other apps besides
default the system writes the
sms approved system but does not write
ms
Okay, so it's just this observation there and then
dss standard he who is responsible for
write the messages in the content
likely to exit itself
so when you send for that price
application but it is he who makes the
because you have to have the
receivables in the correct form you
can handle interaction with others
applications
if you have done a backup ep of
sms
then you will save yourself from disaster to
standard application at least
temporarily to be able to restore the
messages you want to write in the
fitting room
you have to be is standard then you have
expired and made an application that is
backup of sms have to remember to do
this passage to what is standard
even if it is temporarily good good is
more examples there are more explanations in
android developer blog has the link to
next, we'll put it on the
video description ok
visit there ask your questions and enjoy
the resources to do MS proof
better yet and who knows how to become
good user preferred application
Thank you very much in the near future.